avec nous ce soir stéfane marion
économiste et stratège en chef à la
banque nationale bonsoir souvent
monsieur clients alors pipi pib en
hausse de façon spectaculaire excellents
résultats financiers pour google
notamment mais on sent quand même
stéphane montée l'incertitude en bourse
depuis quelques jours dites nous
pourquoi
les marchés boursiers sont démarchés
d'anticipation que je pense que la
bourse avait très bien fait prédit le
rebond économique du troisième trimestre
plus tôt cet été
par contre le problème monsieur fillion
c'est que les attentes de la croissance
pour l'année 2000 21 sont beaucoup plus
incertaine dans un contexte où le
stimuli budgétaires se fait à temps nous
et aussi donc c'est vraiment une folle
de récession parce que le pib baisse les
dépenses de consommation au monde
c'est quand même extraordinaire que nous
avons vécu jusqu'à présent mais pour la
bourse qui est inquiétant c'est les
perspectives de croissance pour le
quatrième trimestre et pour le début
2010 mais est ce qu'il ya un risque de
retour en récession ou de poursuite de
récession là tout dépendamment de quel
point on part avec la hausse des 99 avec
les restrictions en allemagne en france
et peut-être d'autres restrictions à
venir aux états unis vous avez
absolument raison il n'y a pas de livre
de recette magique pour naviguer une
pandémie depuis ce qu'on constate c'est
que la recrudescence des codes coved est
très palpable dans les pays européens
et ça devient généraliser les
gouvernements interviennent en n'y
allant avec des fermetures sectorielle
donc fort à penser que le secteur des
services qui en général au sud de lyon
si 60% du pib pourrait être beaucoup
plus faible au quatrième trimestre et
c'est là mon interrogation les profits
les anticipations profite pour être
beaucoup
m vous nous avez pas préparé d'ailleurs
un graphique sur les anticipations de
profits pour les entreprises
évolution donc depuis le début des
années 2000 on voit clairement dans le
milieu
graphique la chute la des profits lors
de la crise de 2008 2009 la remontée
ensuite la chute lors du 1er confinement
et de l'art et économique
et ce qui est en rouge c'est le rebond
pratiquement enlevé attendue des profits
pour le s&p 500 est-ce que c'est trop
optimistes c'est très agressif parce que
ce que la bourse américaine se transige
à 22 fois les bénéfices escomptés de
l'année prochaine puis bénéfices
escomptés l'année prochaine une
croissance fabuleuse parce qu'on parle
de niveau profite à l'été prochain qui
reviendrait à un record de tous les
temps donc pour que ça se concrétise
beaucoup de choses doivent bien se
dérouler on doit avoir un vaccin qui
qu'ils soient qu'ils soient disponibles
à très court terme on doit un stimuli
budgétaires on connaît pas encore les
résultats légumes des élections
américaines
donc c'est vraiment un scénario de conte
de fées jusqu'à un certain point puis
c'est la raison pour laquelle on est un
petit peu plus sceptique par rapport à
ses attentes là où on n'ose pas vous
dites ça puis en même temps est-ce que
la bourse n'attend pas une victoire de
joe biden est donc un stimuli
budgétaires avec des démocrates qui
serait plus en place à ce moment-là et
vaccins avec tous et est en phase iii
quelque part dans la première moitié
c'est vrai mais il ya quand même
certaines nuances c'est parce que
l'élection de monsieur ben laden n'est
pas une condition suffisante pour avoir
un difficile de réussir gta de grande
ampleur il faudrait qu'il ya un balayage
démocrate qu'on gagne la maison blanche
le sénat et la chambre des représentants
et la scène 40 irait peut-être un
difficile le stim budgétaire d'envergure
pour l'économie américaine mais nous
n'en sommes pas là je pense que c'est un
circuit studio il va planer encore pour
quelques temps puis le déploiement du
verte du vaccin et peut-être que c'est
une histoire seulement pour le deuxième
ou le troisième trimestre de 2021 donc
encore une fois moi avec présentement le
prix du pétrole qui est plus beau que la
volatilité sur le marché boursier
peut-être qu'aujourd'hui ça a été bon
reggae réquilibrage pour certains
investisseurs mais
beaucoup d'incertitudes pour les
prochaines semaines que nous dit le prix
du pétrole là qui est en mode 40 dollar
autour de 40
moi je pense que ce que ça veut dire
c'est qu'avec certains un confinement il
y aura moins d'activité économique dans
les prochaines semaines et donc le prix
des commodités des denrées de base en
général reflète sa carte
cette incertitude lesquels sont les
anticipations par rapport aux résultats
des élections américaines le marché
entre guillemets la prévoit quoi si vous
avez gager monsieur fignon il faut aller
sur des sites est présentement à 53 pour
cent de probabilités pour qu'il ya un
balayage démocrates mais 53% vous allez
me dire que c'est un peu plus que 50 %
mais c'est pas une grosse conviction au
niveau des marchés
et comme mieux pas cette grosse
conviction moi je pense que les
prochains jours seront très importants
pour la direction future des marchés de
même que l'évolution des comptes de
covin alors ne parions sur rien parce
que tout est possible bien sûr stéphane
marion merci merci merci beaucoup